it may be the most dangerous political
flashpoint in the world
china is spending vast amounts on its
military and is sending regular flights
into taiwan's air defense identification
zone
not far away warships of the us navy
alongside the uk japan and other allies
regularly practice combat drills
and in the middle of it are the 24
million people of taiwan a self-governed
democracy so is china preparing for war
the short answer is yes it's actually
written into the chinese constitution
china's constitution says taiwan is part
of the sacred territory of the people's
republic of china it is the inviolable
duty of all chinese people including our
compatriots in taiwan to accomplish the
great task of reunifying the motherland
and in 2005 china passed a law stating
that if the possibilities for a peaceful
reunification should be completely
exhausted the state shall employ
non-peaceful means and other necessary
measures so china is legally committed
to war and thus to some extent must
prepare for it of course it's not framed
as invasion but reunification
and to understand why we need the
backstory
after the end of the second world war
china entered a bloody civil war between
the nationalists or kmt and the chinese
communist party
when the communists triumphed the kmt
fled to taiwan and stayed there imposing
martial law with the backing of the us
so there were two chinas the people's
republic of china on the mainland and
the republic of china on taiwan both
claiming to represent one china
things got more complicated in 1979 when
the u.s formally recognised the people's
republic of china
as a result it now maintained only
unofficial relations with taiwan
although congress did sign a bill to
supply it with defensive weapons since
then the u.s has regarded the taiwan
question as unsettled and has not
explicitly committed to its defence a
policy known as strategic ambiguity
[Music]
strategic ambiguity has actually worked
pretty well so far but two long-term
trends are making it more difficult
first taiwan became a democracy
and with that democracy there's been a
growing sense of taiwanese not chinese
identity on the island
especially in opposition to the
authoritarian system of communist rule
on the mainland
second mainland china became much more
rich and much more powerful and started
spending big on its military
china under president xi jinping has
been much more assertive
[Applause]
it's launched a brutal crackdown in
xinjiang detaining around a million
uygas and other minorities
in the south china sea reefs have been
militarized with airfields built
hong kong has been brought under tight
control the protests of 2019 have been
crushed a national security law
introduced and the already meager
pro-democracy opposition vanquished
so when xi jinping said this
resolving the taiwan question and
realizing china's complete reunification
is a historic mission and an unshakable
commitment of the chinese communist
party it's no surprise that people are
taking the risk of war very seriously
taiwan certainly is this is what its
foreign minister told sky news this is
our country this is our people and this
is our way of life and we will defend
ourselves to the very end
puts china and taiwan's military is
head-to-head and it's rather lopsided
china has around a million ground force
soldiers it has around 350 ships and
submarines and its air force is more
than two and a half thousand aircraft
strong
taiwan on the other hand has around 88
000 army soldiers just over 100 warships
and 460 aircraft
but add in the us and it's a fairer
fight america has nearly 1.4 million
troops around 300 naval vessels and
about 5 500 aircraft
just because china could invade taiwan
doesn't mean that it would there are
enormous costs the big question is
whether the u.s would intervene i've
spoken with xi about taiwan we'll abide
by
the taiwan agreement that's where we are
and we made it clear that i don't think
he should be doing anything other than
abiding by the agreement and even
without u.s intervention china would
face being condemned and cut off by the
rest of the world with economic
sanctions being applied
there is one certainty in all of this if
taiwan were to formally declare
independence china would invade that's
part of the reason for us strategic
ambiguity it doesn't want to guarantee
the island's defense in case that
emboldens it to make that declaration
but that ambiguity is being pushed to
its limits with china using so-called
gray zone tactics to increase the
pressure
china's air incursions are designed to
train its own pilots scope out taiwan's
defenses and wear out its air force
and there are several ways china could
push things even further
it could send planes into taiwan's
direct airspace rather than its air
identification zone it might try seizing
some of the smaller islands that taiwan
controls that lie very close to the
chinese mainland or it could try
blockading taiwan economically all of
those steps would be a real
deterioration but we are not there yet
still with so much military hardware in
the region and with the u.s china
relationship so bad the opportunity for
mistakes does exist and the consequences
would be massive so even if china isn't
preparing for war and that's a big if
events could still lead the world there
[Music]
you